merci madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes également secrétaire général
à la coopération entre la France et
l'Allemagne je peux évidemment pas
m'empêcher de parler des 60 ans du
traité de l'Élysée pour moi toujours un
miracle la réconciliation
franco-allemande et un miracle après 40
ans en France je suis arrivé il y a 40
ans si vous me le permettez sans parler
français de pouvoir être aujourd'hui ici
et de prendre la parole sans que ça pose
plus de problèmes que ça et ça on a je
mesure dans ma vie le chemin parcouru et
je voudrais rappeler une autre date le 9
mai 1950 la le discours de Robert
Schuman anat fondateur qui a en réalité
permis cette réconciliation
franco-allemande et je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi la France n'est pas
plus fière de ça c'est la France qui a
tondu la main à l'Allemagne avec
énormément d'audace et de nous avons
certes divergence mais nous avons
surtout aussi un socle commun nous
sommes attachés à l'état de droit à la
démocratie nous sommes derrière l'Union
européenne et nous soutenons sans faille
le peuple
ukrainien qui nous montre aussi
aujourd'hui une chose extrêmement
importante il n'y a pas de bonheur sans
liberté il n'y a pas de liberté sans
courage sans audace est-ce que nous
aujourd'hui on a encore cette audace et
aujourd'hui nous avons accordé ce statut
de candidat à l'Ukraine ça va être une
discussion très difficile entre nous
mais en réalité on en a besoin d'élargir
et on a besoin par contre aussi une
réforme institutionnelle de l'Union
européenne pour que l'on soit en
capacité d'agir madame la secrétaire
d'État avec votre homologue en allure
man vous avez mis en place un forum
d'expert hier vous êtes venus hier pour
parler justement des dispositions qu'on
peut prendre pour donner un coup de
pouce dans cette union européenne qui
doit faire face à des défis
extraordinaire aujourd'hui
quels sont les démarches à suivre merci
[Applaudissements]